yeah welcome to another episode of the
handsome Rambler podcast I'm here with
my guest host tony trim we're in a
special location a different location we
haven't recorded here before we're not
in my apartment or some hotel room in
some city we're not in Australia that's
some [ __ ] we're not we're in Chicago
recording studios with our special
guests chance the rapper yeah it's going
good man thank you ever come in a
Chicago recording company thank you man
I've been in here before
yeah and that's a wrap yeah I came in
here for courting some voice over there
you working on a Christmas album yeah
yeah yeah this oh it's it's me and
Jeremiah we started in this room yeah
two weeks ago today we we got in here
and I was talking about making a
Christmas Juke song and and Jeremiah was
up here that's my very good friend and
he was like let's make a whole tape and
then we made the whole tape in like two
weeks
nice so it's Christmas it's Christmas
songs for for for ladies you know it's
like more it's because it's you know
it's Jeremiah took the lead on this and
he's a you know he's a sing he's our R&B
superstar every superstar and and and
and that's like any any Kenny and he
took the direction of it so it's like so
it's Merry Christmas lo mama is the
title of ours the working title yeah
played that for me in New York Merry
Christmas mama yeah
yes it's a lively track man I love junk
music I like I still I've never learned
how to footwork for working for you
listeners is what you do to Duke music
yep well you Duke which is when you put
your pelvis on those strangers but yeah
well you're but on a stranger's pelvis
but uh yeah I used to Jew which was just
listen it was easy not dancing as a 16
year old you just kind of just kind of
have your friends hold you back yeah oh
and in just a girl full of energy just a
youthful full of energy girl just backs
it up on you until uh yeah you like it
my still a virgin
yeah I'm still Christmas album that
nobody song right now it's like it's
like nine songs nine songs it's a good
amount of songs great I feel like the
greatest albums are like around nine
nine nine tracks nine tracks I'll give
you a few examples okay all right
have you ever heard gonna have any
backup for my argument I was just
arguing arguing yeah I was gonna I got
some some references all right all right
nine track albums here we go off bat the
college dropout nine tracks what that's
what I wanted to happen know what
happened I was like there was a yeah I
don't know any of my tracks yeah it
seemed you know but mixtape thank you
did in two weeks nine facts that's
that's a great excuse
yeah a student for tuning else craft one
we were shooting for seven and we and we
got at it and we got to like 13 and then
we was like we don't got enough time
yeah so it's like it's finna be knowing
sorry I was late with my first yeah
that's what I didn't it's supposed to be
it was supposed to be 10 it's all good
man it's exciting
how was a SNL for the third time right
yeah technically it was my second time
your second time as as the guest last Oh
guess if I guess that was way yeah yep
yeah and then this time was was me and
third story no name Francis and the
lights me and a whole bunch of my
friends on stage we did same drugs and
finish line it was dope I like I like
going up to SNL because they have like a
really good like the people that are the
the cast and the folks are like work at
the backstage the crew like they're just
all nice people it's like going to camp
it's like a whole week of like being
around these people up at 30 rocket
stove your guests oh yeah I'm the
holiday guest though this is my second
time being a holiday gues holiday guest
everybody's nice but nice yes let's make
a movie together called the holiday
guests and it's like a like a black
Christmas comedy and it's like I come to
visit in town and I'm your cousin yeah
and I'm a regular like accountant and
then you just the [ __ ] up and you just
break up the harmony that's my house but
then we end up learning from each other
at the year yeah I guess we could be or
we could just both be be hilarious I
hate that in comedy there's always like
a straight straight man and then there's
like oh yeah I'm I'm late like we could
both just be crazy and that's the whole
movie this is a pitch you thought
through before you got movie pitches
around here
I have pitched I pitched some sketches
for us and no yeah I had a Kwanza sketch
you went into the the pitch meeting in
Lauren's office or during that I was at
the table reading but I was there on
Tuesday night writing sketches so you
did like 2:00 3:00 in the morning yeah
because I used to write I wrote there
seven years ago yeah weird place for me
I was not good at writing sketches
well I wasn't good at writing sketches
for SNL at the time so you were there
too in the morning and in the writers
offices yeah pitching going going to
each person's room you know I'm saying
popping in giving them ideas I had a few
ideas I'm just gonna shoot them all at
you really fast is it because they're
probably funny and
and all right quite a sketch ginger
fried chicken Hillary Clinton tries odd
jobs at the Obama sketch Kanye West
right it took me like the third one to
realize that they were separate
schedules that didn't make it I used to
pitch six seven Obama my my favorite
sketch that I pitched I pitched this one
call for Dora basketball and it was
where they in the NBA now everybody has
to wear fedoras and while you're on the
court you gotta wear a fedora in
addition to trying to score points and
keep your opponent from scoring points
you also have to keep plant without your
fedora falling off your head
so I'd like somebody cross you up and
you cook up killing about this so I
wrote for Fedora basketball and I was
like psyched about it except my eyes
what you think about this man first of
all this you wrote this this is four
different sets production for this you
have a locker room set you have a
basketball court how we going to shoot a
bet why my skin's wouldn't work maybe
that's what he he also didn't think it
was a good sketch so he just made it
produced an issue maybe was a mixture of
both but I thought those brilliant
Fedora basketball really I might not
just you know put sometimes you got to
just do it yourself do it yourself do it
as a YouTube how to do it yourself man
you can't wait for everybody to learn
your drinks
you got to do it yourself man get y'all
[ __ ] man yo yeah you got your own [ __ ]
you don't know deal yep at first you
like I want to get a deal you like bet I
bet I got a deal
[Laughter]
that was actually one of the first
tracks from ass I bet you people not
that we got linked because and then that
video jazz asked me to direct the video
and it was a the concept we got $5,000
and we just spend it and I want to
apologize I don't know if I ever
apologize for that planning through that
at all I remember we were we were riding
then you're like I'm supposed to direct
this video for Chester rapper and I
don't know what to do
yeah I don't know what to do I got
$5,000 get this famous I would have
really worked hard on that video just we
met I met in LA so you invited me out to
the studio in LA and to play me some
tracks
I think first one you play was a good
ass intro you know I was liking this
[ __ ] at that at Juke [ __ ] which was
actually I played it during one of my DJ
sets in Phoenix I played it and it was
my only successful Blin I'm the worst
blender you ever touch any type of DJ
it's horrible blended Tony sees me DJ
all the time bad at blaming you got the
drops down I got drops you'd be hitting
them drops drops but I uh but it was
just it blended perfectly with a bang
bang bang Skeet Skeet Skeet juicy right
around the same BP every nose
[Music]
you have a DJ too
I got I have like I'm good at picking
songs like making playlist
yeah like or like coming over to the
table at a party and being like a played
a song it's fun to turn this [ __ ] off
yeah but never never have I ever like
got on on the table on the tables and
blended as you yeah people just people
just like that you playing songs that's
what I found people will kind of give
you a a break on the blending I didn't
come to see Funk Flex Tony touched DJ
Clue I can't even see a man they know
from something else play songs but then
you get some people what is this this is
no he's bastardizing the art he's
bastardizing the art chance you gonna
run for mayor no no you can't perfect
place that's so funny
no somebody just actually that recently
and that's the only way I reacted that
way what but I just think that's such a
funny thing like I could right now maybe
like now say like six months from now
[Laughter]
yeah I mean a truck could become
president yeah America you can become
you actually have done good things in
Chicago did you do student government no
I didn't I I did I was on lit mag for a
second what is it it's not what it
sounds like it's not this is a long time
ago yeah I did I tried to be I forgot
what I ran for some student government
off
and then you have to make a speech on
the intercom system about why hello
fellow student I'm Hannibal Buress I am
a junior and I am running for I don't
know if it's class president or what it
was vice president and then I started my
[ __ ] and then I just froze up you know
like yeah I'm happy and I'm bye-bye
who talked you into doing that year old
debate team I think I just had big
ambitions but not follow through at the
time I would have voted for you I don't
think I was ready for politics I realize
I could just affect more change it's
just a normal high school junior and it
was all good Irie listen it's a tenday
and that [ __ ] is super funny now is that
funny like the no no the energy is built
around is this just this this teen angst
cuz I heard it right would it not right
when it came up I remember my buddy
wills like yo this guy check out this
guy from the shot chance the rapper and
I'm like you talk about chance from that
vh1 so nice Chicago rapper you got this
mixtape check it out in this and I like
the songs and I like some of the song
but this is listening to it it's like so
much anger wait how are you
like where's the eggs I was like 17 yeah
[ __ ] you talk what
[Laughter]
[ __ ] this our school and everything time
now
3 4 no 19 [ __ ] I [ __ ] side now the
job is
recently listened to it and yeah and got
the same vibe yeah but it's focused it
was funny just cuz it's mention it's
very themed it's very very the 14400
minutes that's the amount of minutes the
amount of minutes in 10 days yeah I
checked the math on that Justin get out
so that's one time some songs on there
too did you make the chill songs win
[ __ ] you talking about is you it's
almost a monument screwdriver which is
your uh what's your favorite guest verse
that that I yeah both favorite guest
verse of a rapper did you like and then
favorite guest verse you've done I don't
know I can't I can't think of any I'm
like any good guest verses that I've
done but the best guest verse that I got
from somebody is the no name verse on
unlost yeah yeah no name is dope man she
was she might be mad at me for saying
this I ran into her in Brooklyn a couple
of days before the SNL tapered and she
was she was nervous about the two-step
that she had to do oh yeah on camera and
I said just go for it you know I never
had to coach somebody I'll just help
them out also I'm not a great two step
for a dancer at all but I just know a
big part of dancing is total confidence
and having a you gotta have a face like
you're killing it that's always great
advice don't just go for it just go for
it I don't have has it yeah and then
just yeah but she was nervous about
she's like I gotta do this two-step
oh yes yes she smashed it she stole the
show it was it was a really cool thing
and you know I've known I've known no
name since I was 14
JIT and I met her to go through the
library she went to to you media and
hello Washington and yeah she was she
was into like in the writing like very
early on like when I was still a kid and
I was like trying to do my poetry thing
and yeah and and we we had the same
mentor this guy brother Mike and uh we
would go to his own for mics together
and YCA together just always like I've
known her for my whole life
you know and it was very cool to be
together on on SNL but rappin yeah I
noticed I noticed that when you have get
when you have guests on your tracks most
of the time you always go first
is there a yeah you notice that like you
were always done my song
you know you never have a guest go first
think about that that's what me and
Hannibal knows that one day because
we're just driving it's like you know
this chances guests never go first
Hannibal you made that you made that
observation yeah I'm trying to I'm
trying to think of something on the
contrary but I can't think of one
obviously it's not by choices just
happens that way right
that's real I think also I do I what's
crazy is on the Christmas project which
isn't just my saw of my project but
there's a bunch of songs for other
people straight the first four yeah this
is off topic a little bit but you know
what weird song has been stuck in my
head but I think it's from volume 3jz
you know why I stuck it yes doc Carter
your most heart and there's a music
competition is not yes doc Carter no
competition is no no no that's in my
head for some reason you know track I'm
song I have no idea
harder video no no no what no like see
you know eighties y'all could have clown
me cuz I didn't just have goddamn
cassette tapes in my pocket I don't know
why I was in my head
I haven't even listened to that in a
long time yeah
the brain is weird man yeah I'm
forgetting way more important things
didn't a hook to that song but it was
just in my own wife it was in my head
yes caught up yes yes
Carter how you be coming up with an lips
would you like at first you would like
to be bit but you know different sounds
I've had the same same ad-libs for a
long time now and I was actually just
recently thinking about a new yeah a few
not it's not like I mean you can go with
a range of but out yeah you want some
suggestions lips go well you can wear
mine and I'm find licenses it you know
it's like motorcycle oh yeah that's just
oh yeah you know that just sounds like a
lightsaber turning uh you know Kid Cudi
I mean I've listened to Cuddy for a
while but I listen to the track with him
in a willow
Smith is this track called was a car
rolls golden and he's he's moaning like
a [ __ ] on there it's a good song
be like oh he's saying like he's making
up his song third Hannibal has been
literally singing this all day and he
started with the mid-south Willow Smith
singing on it just harmonizing just the
whole time inside so well when you
listen to his like humming ad-libs it's
a little he had to be high as [ __ ] I
like it but it's like not a the
structure of it and the whole thing is
from a high mind yeah how's the house
the triplets the triplet triplet triplet
oh the baby are you talking about a
three thing are you talking about that
my actual child yeah I was you had the
one yeah you have one I only have one
kid
uh-oh I'm 23 that's [ __ ] read some
bad articles man wait you heard that he
had triplets we can't just pretend like
you didn't just say that's what the
research says I've never heard the
chances yes we look at different
websites like that you know I had that
fake Trump news backs okay
how did you do fifteen months is she
taking on is she rapping already Jesus
she has to be no she's around this dude
all the time
she's rapping and dancing she's
definitely a singer she is she does dude
she's she's a dancer too yeah kids just
absorb [ __ ] she's like mimicking you
when you start like singing the rapping
that she started trying to be like pops
it's not to that level so like I said
she's like 15
yeah she doesn't have like I don't know
child development though yeah no there's
a it goes yeah how'd you get this
podcast I just asked for a podcast you
can just do it's nothing I want to do a
podcast and if people say alright cool
you wanna advertise socks on it you just
want me to read this about socks
podcasts are the comedian's equivalent
to a rappers mixtape because you're
putting them out all the time you're
giving people free material building the
buzz for when your main project comes
out you've built that energy in that
goodwill hopefully so that's what it is
so it's been fun cuz I just gonna say
all types of wild [ __ ] and then I'll
listen to it well I listened to it and
into practice and if I don't like it
I'll cut it out Hannibal's being very
reserved right now usually on the on the
podcast freestyles auto-tune sings his
ass what can live out it so well we do
it in post
yeah we do it is wrong if you want to
hear some vocals I can I can fix it up
for you give him some Hannibal that
he'll bounce but out don't die don't die
down down down down down up but don't
don't don't don't you ever make beats
not no not really
no I like standing the studio and and
and ask people to play stuff but I don't
I don't know how to like use Ableton or
like Pro Tools
you're like a conductor almost
yeah where you say where you can be like
horns right here take a little off over
there
[Laughter]
all right quiet yeah do you think the
choirs ever do old people would acquire
everybody why is this young man they're
just excited I feel like I'll be because
sometimes you be coaching these people
like no don't sing like that singing
like this and anything we sing for the
Lord I would sing for the Lord for years
now this chance of a young man chance I
gotta ask yourself I was I was I was
interested in this I noticed that there
in the time that you were working with
Kanye well you were all over Kanye [ __ ]
he started he started getting all gospel
II and I know that you were on that
already was that any kind of influence
that you had on him was the other way
around or a hot cuz all of a sudden it
just seemed like Kanye was all about the
gospel [ __ ] I feel like that was kind of
sensationalized though you know we had
an idea like I think he just made one
tweet where he said yeah this album is a
gospel album yeah after the night after
I'll give you true Intel is that you
know it was the night after I hung out
with him in the studio and I started
playing him records that that uh he
asked me to work on an ultralight beam
but it wasn't really being yet it was
just yeah he said well he wanted to make
a good Friday song they were making it
from scratch and uh when we started
making the beat I I was like let's
listen to some music for some
inspiration I had been listening to
Graham and his mother she liked that and
yeah and then he he tweeted that it was
a he was working on a gospel album but
he didn't I don't think he like really
like fully felt that it post yeah
tweeting that
I mean he did it like Kirk Franklin on
the side and he had all that other you
know items that was really just that one
song on the show
Jesus or young jeezy who said it Jesus
or young jeezy Snowman [ __ ] I don't
even wear the same drawers who said it
Jesus for young jeezy
[Music]
fine next one Jesus Oh young jeezy fish
and wine for everybody who turned up who
said Jesus I've been to the Open Mic a
couple times man that [ __ ] is live it's
a live event yeah I enjoyed I brought my
little niece and nephew through their
things man yeah I remember yeah
how wait how old is he I think he's nine
you ever watched a Tony Robbins doctor
really
Tony Robbins no who's Tony Robbins he's
a motivational speaker wait was he an uh
have you seen shallow how probably with
Jack Black
I haven't seen that but is he at all to
do yeah and a booming voice and you can
live life yeah he's a motivational
speaker people paid thousands of dollars
to go see him you have like a kind of an
obsession with Tony Robbins you bring
him up a lot
what is it about Tony Robbins that you
so are you inspired by him well you know
it was well it was in I was in a certain
city in the Midwest and this this girl
came through well tell her we smoke weed
and watch the Tony Robbins documentary
and it just was on or did she suggest
that we watched some Tony Robbins no I
suggested it because I was like she was
already hypnotized some ways she's so
into a stranger's home today
we never met it all before it's very
weird but I'm so part of me I think cuz
I was high I was like Joe maybe this
dude is right yeah maybe is or maybe
it's a hoax yeah and then another theory
I have about tony robbins and
motivational speakers in general i
wonder if they do things to destroy
people like maybe they go to a bar in
disguise give a bunch of people drugs
and then those people go home and are
mean to their families and then those
people at home there that they were mean
to are broken and then they have to pay
money for tony robbins seminars or maybe
just a cult leader music oh I don't know
you could I be you can follow a cult who
does like talks and everyone believe
people get hyped who does he go - who
does Tony Robbins go to for motivation
chance who does he talk to does he just
watch his own [ __ ] to get hyped some
rappers listen to their own music yeah
or he he was in he was in that he
doesn't probably doesn't need motivation
because he's not a motivational speaker
this is really tall he was in the Jack
Black movie
he's got fans yeah Tony thinks same
drugs about drugs and I was telling him
that well you know I know it's not about
that but that would be funny if you like
man you do heroin now I'm at it was a
literal at all it wasn't literal at all
or was there any kind of yeah it could
be literal yeah it can be uh-huh you
just use it for your life
sometimes I take rap lyrics out of
context
yeah and just apply them to my [ __ ] oh
yeah you know like sometimes you know
you ever hear that Devon - dude song
which one he made a song called boo
booing boo boo
bullying he made a song about being on
the toilet boo booing what do you use it
for it what's the context to either
that's just just everyday life even if
I'm not on the toilet I just think about
that cameras got a song about his IBS
all-time camera about IBS that's real
[ __ ] though okay yeah I'll be in the
bathroom boo-boo when he describes the
whole scene that has nothing to do with
using toilet for the whole verse I guess
that cycle next level poop joke right
there wait builds up to it I mean I feel
like he was just done with the first
like he's good with the joke that way
does he ever hit you up like you know
what I'm thinking about changing the
vocals all stronger changes he was
making on Pablo like I go listen to
something and then it'll just be one
party to be like because we were on
though I remember we were on the road
and we were listening to it but we were
also listening to the updates
yeah upgraded versions yeah it's like oh
[ __ ] you knows what he did right there I
think he did he did I was kind of cool
though I thought it was yeah he did some
stuff too father stretchy definitely
yeah I think a couple other other things
is that the first time I guess cuz
that's more of a new time digital thing
what somebody's gone in and changed his
music I thought it was dope that's cool
it's like a never change like it's
always growing and evolving good for ya
yeah good for him lord knows I got some
jokes I wish I could switch up now
yeah cuz you feel you beyond that like
god damn is out there forever when you
tweet you so yeah and unstructured and
just oh man
I know I know Avery like for real do you
want us to put the new okay whatever man
alright you can put it back up so I saw
in the studio you're wet you're seven
songs and I saw the board yeah it's
right next to each songs that's done
done done I saw like maybe two or three
oh yeah we're not so where are you right
now we're yeah we got two songs left
yeah and we're gonna drop we got just
like some low and it's yeah some tiny
changes so you just tweaking right now
and then yeah there's okay let's make it
like a radio so we were gonna put in one
of the songs earlier later yeah and we
get and we got an exclusive right here
on handsome rambling radio a new track
for chance and Jeremiah
it's called Merry Christmas little mama
or it might be one of the other ones
have a listen
[Music]
[Music]
little man
alright that was awesome you guys oh man
people on me fill in the spirit that was
amazing I was dope I just felt very
inspired the Juke drums is that as
people be like I'm tired of this house
[ __ ] let's speed it up on that that's
pretty much how some music is boys like
enough of this [ __ ]
we need to speed this up and chant over
it just should I just think about this
like who was the first band ski ski ski
ski ski skis I mean like they put that
say that record over a fast ass beat and
there's somebody like wasn't it fun oh
[ __ ] okay Swiss I said oh [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] who is great you ever thought
about just going like doing a straight
like Juke EP you something because I
know you love that [ __ ] yeah I've
thought about I can't really like
produce an entire Juke tape because I
can't really make beats yeah but I do
like to you get executive producer one
right yeah I feel like there's so much
effort it's just there's still plenty of
good you know yeah I think it outside
Chicago and maybe Detroit Juke is taken
by the rest of the world in small doses
but if you put the chance stamp on it
you might be able to open some minds
except for it and you know where people
there's like in some and some places in
Asia there's like very big footwork
scenes really like yeah entirely like
Asian
dance crews from like just recent new
sit like just because they just stumbled
upon in the side it's just like ah go
for work and then somebody saw that
sitting look at this everybody yeah I
guess they just heard the music and then
knew what that [ __ ] was I follow like a
page that does really what is that page
it's called Jukes um I don't know there
is it's a dance crew though yes from the
African Asian juke crew yeah this is
exclusive rare Instagram [ __ ] man I will
watch I'll watch that all the time try
to pick up this too late for me to start
full working on 33 [ __ ] ankles yeah
man my ankles are crumbling bowlegged I
can't do it anymore
it takes a lot of cardio yeah I see a
chance I see you up there
you kind of incorporate it into your
into your live show yeah so you got to
be fit you got a you got to get into the
cardio part of it right because you
[ __ ] jump in high as [ __ ] well you
power push up was SoulCycle yeah I don't
I don't work out I I should though cuz
they don't have more energy but you're
like an athlete on stage you're very
athletic that's the workout that's the
workout you just do shows that's what
you got the breath control
that's a [ __ ] cardio that's a
cardiovascular ass workout that's my
workout too is my shows except for thank
you I just get exhausted talking just
one bit that has a big performance to it
this real physical whoa that bit I don't
know the rest of this show being bad
how's your writer changed
what's the evolution I've seen the
evolution of the the crowds
what's the evolution
of the rider i have mac and cheese now
we recently got cards playing cards yeah
yeah and you know and Whitey's Whitey's
yeah the new homage to them franchise
boys just independent yeah its
independence new developer that's my
thing right I was telling handable
that'd be great for the rider fresh
underwear we have fresh underwear as
well see I told you I'm not crazy about
that then size drawers and socks every
gig if you're touring you need all those
that's what I'm saying see I'm not crazy
seven times now I should cancel the tour
and see what the [ __ ] myself seven times
there's a week left of shells away I
gotta go figure some stuff I gotta go
get a pepto-bismol IV or something
I gotta go back in that other room and
finish the Christmas cool yeah there's a
full studio in here so if you also want
to you know just I'll work over there's
auto-tune in here too I work over here
then I'll uh I'll bounce it over to you
exactly is that that's no that's right
that's the lingo yeah I'll put it on
I'll put on the flash and I bounce it
and then I throw it over there that's it
and then you just put it on the track
fly it in Metro boomin Thank You Man
thank you for taking time out of
wrapping my old friends the Wednesday
album it's coming out what's the date
that you're I'm trying to drop it
tonight tonight which is what the 20 is
this twenty third twenty second twenty
second twenty second twenty twenty first
twenty first but if your nerd in his mid
night is a twenty second but also
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
keep your clothes no clothes
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh China deal
tell me where's Flo should I get off
I'll be right there to set it off I'll
be right there the dagger heart
[Music]
at all your presence is appraising farm
for Christmas so just because CBO love
they are loved
our Christmas
oh I love Christmas being obligated to
buy [ __ ] for people at a certain time of
the year I buy Christmas gifts but just
just cuz she's supposed to
Jesus auto-tune ad for it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I got if you leave my raw
vocals like that we're not friends
anymore I don't so my city put them put
them Travis Scott effects on my [ __ ]
[Music]
you